Oh AAA wait wait I got it so I'm
scrolling down Instagram this morning by
the way the crater of drill DME no way
he goes thanks for shouting me out
that's funny to you man your accountant
is your cat caboodle [ __ ] hardcore
man oh damn some of the and you know
what the crazy [ __ ] about that account
is that we're just gonna talk about
drilling in for 10 minutes but like
every like 12th video is just a video of
someone dancing oh is it
and I'm like waiting for them to get
killed it never happens and I'm like
weirdly awesome weird why keep me on my
toes like this kind of like that one
no it's like boring and weird as like
it's like I don't understand in the next
video is someone getting murdered
oh yes bow to the face our back in yeah
oh yeah yeah dude that's our advice to
you just friendly advice you know maybe
without the dancing it's not really
ombre it's not very on the dancing video
I want to see more people dying yeah
let's get that let's get some death dude
mm-hmm
yeah drilled maybe think of two things
one it makes me think of when I worked
at a call center and I we would just be
like watching liveleak uh-huh like
that's this picture that someone calling
in about their bank account I'm like
uh-huh yeah let me open up your account
and there's just no spark or deaths yeah
or just on my screen it's just silently
like a dude getting launched by a car
all right yeah just pulling up your
account here in your head wish that was
me okay was your customer number go
ahead hold on one second you know that
guy just gave my brake oh I don't have
to do some research on this yo Taylor
hey I'm sending you a link this is
[ __ ] crazy this guy gets killed by a
brick all right yeah just give me a few
more minutes here you see that [ __ ]
nuts dude he got nailed with a pill dude
he's dead as [ __ ] nay oh my god anyways
that your account negative Jamie hold
the video here
you had the video a deer getting hit by
that car I didn't feel like I did joe
rogan justice on that yeah man it's why
it's [ __ ] crazy like that yeah you've
seen those [ __ ] monkeys out there and
East Africa that they pretty coconuts
with their bare hands he was on other
kind of dexterity where's that dexterity
come from anyway have you seen that guy
that guy in Russia who got killed by
those teenagers when he killed him with
a hammer yeah they put a hammer in a bag
he just [ __ ] head open Jamie can you
look that up please
meanwhile another side some nonprofit
yeah yeah I came here to talk about
make-a-wish I'm not like I was for some
reason I was like going through podcast
on the [ __ ] car screen whatever and
I'm like and I like I didn't have like
it was in traffic or some [ __ ] so I'm
just like whatever Joe Rogan was the
first one so I just clicked it and I was
like the most recent episode and it was
some dude that runs like again it was
like someone some web site it wasn't
convenient or anything it was like I
forget what the website even was some
content website or something yeah seemed
like a smart guy I don't know but the
first thing he said was yeah man I just
turned 30 and it's weird you know it's
it's really weird it's the first time
where you know when I was 29 I had like
you know 30 seconds before my 30th
birthday I was like you know enjoy this
is the last 30 seconds that you're
you're 29 or whatever and Joe Rogan was
like yeah yeah it's it's fascinating
it's fascinating how we we fight age you
know it's fascinating it's like it's
like its natural it's gonna happen and
these people are going out and getting
plastic surgery and they're fighting age
and I'm like what and he's like you seem
botched that's a show yeah and that is
just oh people people you know [ __ ] up
nose jobs and stuff it's one girl
actually her nose collapsed she'd so
many rhinoplasty her nose
collapsed and this episode was about the
doctor putting the nose together this is
all Joe one trainer from this guy's 30th
birthday the [ __ ] collapsed nose jobs
in like 45 seconds and the dude was just
like yeah that sounds nuts I was like
scared this is Joe right here it's
[ __ ] up that's [ __ ] up
it's [ __ ] up and what were you saying
about yeah you say somebody dear or
Jamie we get that video that dear
[Laughter]
there's an awkward solid silence Jamie
my guess what yeah yeah yeah Jamie get
the video of that dear the thing yeah
yeah this one you seen this one this is
so good we needed a [ __ ] TV right
here yeah we do yeah it would be solid
yeah eight I want to see Joe one time
just be like yeah man that's that's
crazy
Jamie can you get this guy the [ __ ] out
of the studio he isn't I don't know man
it's just not working for me yep sure
Joe don't no worries I got it yeah the
other thing that have you seen the video
of the I remind you suck I was gonna
pull up the video of the deer but I know
you're not gonna enjoy it
so get out [ __ ] I've got some clothes
[Music]
yes our Dustin home
[Music]